wir helfen den allerkleinsten in ihrer
praxis in berlin-mitte doktor silke
wechsler und partner von der pandemie
sind natürlich auch kinder betroffen
immer wieder auf die sorge hat mein kind
kuren
ich gucke jetzt mal gerade das wissen
kleiner patient uns denken wir sehr sehr
gut
hat fieber leichtes fieber und husten
getestet wird dann mit
sicherheitskleidung im hof der klinik
wirklich direkt produzieren immer wieder
ein stresstest für die besorgten eltern
ein tag in der kita
der test ist diesmal zum glück negativ
seit einem jahr ist das alltag für silke
weidner und drk sostmann eltern
beruhigen zuhören fragen dies geht nach
über einem jahr coruna sind familien mit
den kräften am kaum schule und kita
auf vielen kindern die mail die gerade
erst deutsch lernt macht die pandemie zu
schaffen
ein kleiner bruder rückt näher ran zum
trösten
[Musik]
das war einfach sehr hart als das alles
angefangen hat manche meiner freunde die
in einem anderen land leben konnte ich
nicht mehr sehen
auch meine großeltern nicht mehr in der
schule haben wir zwei gruppen
meine freunde sind in der anderen zu
fehlen mir sehr
[Musik]
ich wünschte corona beer vorbei das
homeschooling ist eine herausforderung
für alle auch für milan und seinen papa
[Musik]
am anfang schon sehr positiv noch einen
engagiert wollten das alles managen und
machen und jetzt merkt man einfach dass
die müde sind also die sind erschöpft
alle eigentlich sind geladen geht die
puste aus und gerade bei den ganz
kleinen mit der note betreuung ist das
oft ein riesenproblem
weil die dann in gruppen kommen wo sie
die erzieher nicht kennen würde die
erzieherin
sich mit ihren freunden sind und es ein
großer stressfaktor auch für meike
martens und ihre tochter holly holy
gehört zur risikogruppe und darf seit
über einem jahr nicht mehr in die kita
es gibt schon so sagen wo ich merke dass
sie angestrengt da ist also so was wie
fingernägel knabbern und so sachen also
die machst du sonst nicht oder auch mit
ihrem verhalten für holly bedeutet dass
keine anderen kinder seit über einem
jahr
merke auch so spielplätzen oder so dass
ihr der kontakt mit anderen kindern hat
schwerer fällt ich weiß irgendwie gar
nicht so richtig wie das geht so mein
eindruck dass das für uns glaube ich für
alle irgendwie so ein bisschen nicht ein
bisschen ist furchtbar zu sehen wenn da
so kinder gut miteinander spielen und
wir hatten
paulis eltern sind selbstständig und
betreuen sie nun fast alleine
die werden einfach zurückgelassen die
kinder und die familie familien lange
schaffen sie das so nicht mehr
diese schicksale hören sie oft in der
kinderarztpraxis viele eltern fühlen
sich vergessen in den fragen nach
priorisierung und hilfen
naja ich finde das mikrofon akademie
wieder ganz generell aufzeigt was
politisch falsch läuft wenn man gegen so
über noch nie einfluss zum beispiel
spricht und solche dinge
sie machen sich sorgen ob ihre kräfte
reichen und vor allem darum wie sehr die
auswirkung von corona die entwicklung
ihrer kinder beeinflusst weil sie so
traurig war dass ich gedacht habe
[Musik]
kleinsten also ich hab noch nie so viele
neue diagnosen für depressive
verschwörungen depressive störung oder
verstimmung oder eben eine echte
endogenen depression gestellt wie in
diesem jahr vor allem bei kindern in
altersgruppen finde ich das vorher gar
nicht kannte die wirklich teilweise
verzweifelt sind und eben natürlich
angststörungen tic störungen also ganz
viele dinge die auftreten die man vorher
in dieser häufung nicht gesehen hat und
die eltern auch ganz klar sagen dass das
pandemie bedingt und die ganz kleinen da
haben wir das war auch also für mich
jetzt sehr beeindruckend so in den
letzten wochen dass die wenn die in der
kita sind in so einer
betreuungsgruppe und dann bei erzieherin
und erzählen die sie nicht kennen oder
auch kinder die sie nicht kennen dass
sie tatsächlich relativ dramatisch
wieder anfangen einzulassen oder sogar
ein zu quoten und das ist immer ein
großes alarmzeichen also wenn ein
vierjähriges kind das lange trocken war
wieder ein nest oder oder sogar 1 quote
dann weiß man dass das kind maximal
gestresst obwohl das kind das nie
ausdrücken würde wahrscheinlich proaktiv
oder vielleicht selbst bei nachfrage
nicht und das andere ist natürlich dass
eltern zum beispiel alleinerziehende
eltern oder auch paare die kinder
erziehen
was ist denn wenn die beiden anträgen
und richtig krank werden also wer
kümmert sich denn dann um die kinder
also wenn die sind für mich hinter und
betreut oder wie ist die jeweilige
großeltern können um sollen bauliche
einspringen
es fehlt ihnen an unterstützung und
perspektiven berichten viele eltern
hinzu kommt die sorge selbst an corona
zu erkranken
drk ist man fordert daher eltern nun
priorisiert zu impfen
das natürlich sobald genug impfstoff da
ist das entsprechend die eltern hören
kategorisiert werden und auch in die pin
der priorisierung nach oben rutschen
beispielsweise auch als eigene
berufsgruppe beide mutter oder vater zu
sein es eigentlich auch nicht ganz
anerkannter also schlecht anerkannter
beruf aber es ist also gesellschaftlich
wichtiger für ihn sind kleine kinder mit
pflegebedürftigen gleichzusetzen
ich kann überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen
warum die kinder jetzt nicht wichtig
sein sollen die müssen in die schule die
müssten ihren sport man die müssen ihre
freunde treffen
die wollen auch ihre großeltern treffen
und die müssen verachtung gesucht nein
auch dafür werden sie hier in berlin
weiter sorgen